Das Podcast Ufo. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Podcast-UFO. Die Kulturzeit, das Kulturufe heute. Vielen Dank für das Intro, fantastisch. Vielen, vielen Dank an Max, der das eingesungen hat, ganz grossartig, vielen Dank, fantastisch. Wir gehen immer in verschiedene Richtungen, wir hatten schon Jazz, Ska und jetzt das. Und jetzt, ja, nenn es ruhig beim Namen. Ja, der Tristan, der gute Alte Tristan, hat uns auch mal besucht, vielen Dank. Aber war das alles Max oder war das sein Barber-Cotet? Ich glaube, das ist Max plus Barber und alle weiteren.
Ich glaube, es ist Max plus Max plus Max.
Ich meine, wer hat das denn nicht gemacht damals, als wir alle das erste Mal Garageband aufgemacht haben, einfach 20 Mal die eigene Stimme und dann schön Abba gesungen mit allen Stimmen.
Weil je mehr Stimmen du hast, desto weniger hört man die 80 Prozent Stimmen raus, die völlig falsch singen.
Du bist ja Podcaster, professioneller.
Ja.
Würdest du sagen, dass du immer noch genervt bist, deine eigene Stimme zu hören oder hast hast du dich mittlerweile daran gewöhnt, oder würdest du sagen, du hörst dich mittlerweile sogar selber eher mit der Stimme, mit der dich auch andere hören? Ach, geht eigentlich, also es ist immer noch eine grosse Verachtung, also wirklich ein grosser Ekel, der immer noch mitschwingt, wenn ich meine eigene Stimme höre. Disgust. Aber ich versuche mich dann immer mehr auf dich zu konzentrieren und versuche mehr die Fehler bei dir zu suchen, um mich so ein bisschen zu verdammten zu lassen. Dann ist er auch okay. Aber nee, es geht eigentlich mittlerweile. Aber das habe ich gemacht. Ich weiß noch, ich habe damals Soosters Breakout komplett als A Cappella eingesungen. Ich weiß nicht, wer das geht. Grossartig. Der Credit-Song von Madagaskar, ein Song von Hans Bambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambamb Ich habe damals im Kino gesehen und dachte mir, wow, vergiss den Film. Von mir aus zeigt mir zwanzig mal die Credits mit dem geilen Song. Und es ist großartig. Kommt doch nicht im Film vor, Seusses Breakout. Oder zumindest nur an einer Stelle, die aber nicht auf dem Soundtrack zu finden ist. Aber ich meine, sind wir doch mal ehrlich, die Creditsongs sind immer die besten Songs. Meistens ist es ja eine Suite, also ein zusammengesetztes Konglomerat aus den Songs, die ihm... Dann sag doch Konglomerat. Mein Gott, wir sind doch hier nicht in der Kneipe.
Man muss doch nicht so eine Proletensprache wie Sweet hier sagen.
Dann sag doch wenigstens Konglomerat.
Das ist auch ein Satz, der noch nie gesagt wurde.
Ja, dann sag doch wenigstens Konglomerat.
Ja, aber das stimmt.
Und das habe ich dann damals nachgesucht.
Auf YouTube findet man hier und da mal Sachen.
Hört es euch an, das ist grossartig.
Und das habe ich nachgesungen.
Sechzig stimmig irgendwie, mit vierzig
Stimmen bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam
grauenvoll. Furchtbar, es klingt
scheusslich, absolut scheusslich.
Und macht aber
trotzdem Spaß auf jeden Fall.
Ist ja glaube ich so der Aber-Effekt, dass die immer
zwanzig mal ihre Stimme haben, einfach damit
so ein bisschen voller klingt
und man vielleicht so ein paar Fehler nicht raus hört. Ich will nicht sagen, dass Aber nicht singen kann. Also bitte versteht mich jetzt nicht falsch. Ist die schon eine dritte Spitze in ein paar Folgen jetzt? Ja, irgendwie ABBA finde ich ist gutes Reimschema mittelmässige Band, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Wie kurz davor waren die sich Baba zu nennen? Baba. Oder Abab, ich weiß es nicht. Aber es gibt hundertprozentig eine Coverband, die Baba heisst und die nur Abba-Song spielst. Oder Barb, kann es auch sein. Barb, Barb, Barb, Barb, Barb, kann es auch geben, ich weiß es nicht. Alles cool. Ja, fantastisch, also Suster's Breakout, ich dachte, ich wäre der einzige, der in seiner Kindheit vor allem damit verbracht hat, Suster's Breakout zu finden. Endlich treffe ich mal jemanden nach all den Jahren, der genau so, vielleicht schreien da draußen jetzt acht Menschen auf, die sagen, ja, ich habe auch so lange nach Zusters Breakout gesehen. Zusters Breakout. Grossartig. Ich weiß gar nicht, wer Zuster ist. Ich habe den Film Madagaskar größtenteils verdrängt. Die Zuster, die Zoobewohner, the Zusters. Ach, the Zusters. The Zusters. Moment mal, Leute, die im Zoo leben, nennt man Zooster? Tiere, die im Zoo leben, sind, glaube ich, in der englischen Synchronfassung The Zoosters. Die Zooster? So, und die Zooster ... Mama, ich will die Zooster sehen! Ja, aber jetzt bin ich natürlich mit meinem Riesenbrain davon ausgegangen, wenn der Song The Zoosters Breakout heisst, ist es wahrscheinlich der Song, der kommt, wenn sie aus dem Zoo ausbrechen. Und bin dann im Soundtrack meinig dahin gewandert, habe den aber da nicht gefunden. Ich weiß auch nicht, vielleicht war der zu phänomenal, zu fulminant, weil man dachte, das lenkt die ganzen Zuschauer ab, dass es zu verrückt ist. Es ist ein grandioser Song für die Credits. Für die Credits. Habe ich damals auf dem Klavier dann abgehört, weil ich in den Genuss kommen wollte, es nochmal zu hören. Aber wie Mozart quasi, bin ich aus dem Kino und habe mich ans Klavier gesetzt. Und dann kam meine Mutter ein und hat gesagt, was spielst du da? Ich habe Zeus' Breakout. Das klingt scheusslich. Ich spiele Zeus' Breakout. Das habe ich im Kino, ich kann den Soundtrack noch nicht hören, deswegen spiele ich jetzt nach auf dem Klavier. Da bin ich mit meinem Gedächtnispalast, war noch jede Note an seinem Platz.
Wir haben es dir zu verdanken, dass Soosters Breakout es überhaupt aus dem Kinosaal geschafft hat, dass es überhaupt ins allgemeine Liedgut übernommen wurde?
Verständnis, ins allgemeine, ja, ins allgemeine Verständnis.
Zoster-Verständnis.
Zoster, Zoster-Ausbruch.
Aber ich denke mir auch tatsächlich, ich sehe selten Zootiere hier und da mal in GIF auf giphy.org und denke mir immer, jedes Tier im Zoo plant den Ausbruch. Ich denke mir immer, die gucken da so rum und gucken und manche offensichtlicher als andere. Und zwar am offensichtlichsten ja offensichtlich Panther slash Geparden slash Leoparden slash Tiere, die so luchsähnliche Tiere, die immer den Zaun systematisch nach Schwachstellen absuchen, weil die ja immer dann quasi im Kreis gehen an diesen und wenn da mal irgendwann ein Stab fehlt, sind die sofort raus, weil die die immer abgehen. Die kommen sofort raus, die gucken, die sehen das, aber wollen erst mal da nicht sich aufhalten, die sind schlau, die laufen da dran vorbei, damit niemand Aufmerksamkeit bekommt und dann irgendwann sind sie weg. Dann die ganzen Antilopen, die immer so gegen die Wand klopfen. Ja, nach Hohlräumen absuchen. Alle drei Zentimeter klopfen sie so mit dem Kopf. Was machen sie da? Was machen sie da? Das ist Instinkt, immer vor der Brunftszeit. Das ist nur unser Instinkt. Das klopfen wir da gegen die Wand, so als wären es Bäume, weil wir hinterlassen da mit dem Geweih so Duftnoten. Man könnte fast annehmen, Sie suchen die Wand systematisch nach Schmachstellen. Nein, nein, nein, ein Irrtum, nein, nein, das ist ganz tief in meinem Instinkt eingebrannt. Ich kann da gar nichts dagegen tun, also ich muss das quasi tun. Gegen Instinkt kann man nichts tun. Und das können Sie gerne erforschen, bitte, also da habe ich nichts dagegen, ich kann Ihnen da sämtliche Daten zur Verfügung stellen, aber ein Ausbruch. Was zum Teufel machen Pfau noch im Zoo? Die sind schon rausgekommen aus dem Gehege, laufen oft auf den Wegen wie normale Besucher an, sind aber wie so Bragging, laufen dann noch vorbei an den anderen, wie ich aber auch, wenn ich aus dem Gefängnis ausbrechen würde, würde ich auch erstmal an allen Gehegen vorbeilaufen und so reinwinken. An allen Zoos dann, ja. Aber die Pfauen sind ja schon ausgebrochen, statt aber rauszufliegen, fliegenweise nicht, deren Flügel nicht gestürzt sind, aber statt einfach rauszugehen mit den Besuchern, verbringen die weiterhin Zeit im Zoo. Ich glaube, das ist das klassische Shawshank Redemption Problem, die sind ausgebrochen, waren in der Außenwelt und haben dann gemerkt, dass sie dort doch nicht glücklich wären. Sondern dass sie in all der Zeit im... Da geht es ihnen doch sehr gut, außerhalb des Gefängers. Nee, der hat sich doch umgebracht. Spoiler. Nein. Oder? Nein, die laufen doch am Ende, sie laufen sich zusammen in die Arme, da ist doch die Encarnates-Spoiler. Ich glaube, ich habe den abgebrochen irgendwann, aber wie können die sich umarmen, wenn der sich umgebracht hat? Oder hat der versucht, sich umzubringen? Einer hat sich umgebracht. Ja, stimmt. Es gibt einen, der ausbricht, der freikommt und sich umbringt, aber der ist auch schon sehr alt. Aber die Hauptfigur nicht. Oder die Person ist alt. Die Person ist sehr alt. Die beiden Hauptfiguren, Morgan Freeman und Tim Robbins? Moment mal, du meinst, also was ist die Moral von dem besten Film der Welt? Je länger man im Gefängnis bleibt, desto größer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man sich so sehr an das Leben gewöhnt, dass wenn man draußen ist, nicht damit klarkommt. Aber wenn du nur eine relativ kurze Zeit im Gefängnis bist, dann ist okay. Also wenn man jemandem lange die Freiheit nimmt, dann gewöhnt er sich an die Unfreiheit und empfindet die Freiheit als Unfreiheit? In dem Film geht es ja vor allem auch um Anpassungsfähigkeit und die Hauptfigur ist natürlich sehr anpassungsfähig. Sie schafft es auch im Gefängnis aus seinen Fähigkeiten, schafft er es, das Bestmögliche zu machen und das Bestmögliche Ergebnis für sich und alle anderen zu erzielen. Als er rauskommt, aber ja auch, dann besucht er ja morgen Freeman. Aber jetzt fasst doch mal die Moral zusammen, das lernen wir von dem Film. Dass man sich immer gut anpassen sollte, um für sich und andere das bestmögliche Ergebnis zu erzielen. Okay, gut, dass du das noch hinzugefügt hast. Aber jetzt lassen Sie mich bitte den Zaun weiterhin auf systematisch nach Schwachstellen untersuchen. Aber auch so Maulwürfe einsperren muss wahnsinnig schwer sein, oder? Ich dachte, Geparden einsperren muss wahnsinnig schwer sein, weil es das schnellste Tier der Welt ist. Wie haben die das gefangen? Stimmt, wenn der einmal ausbricht, das war's. Da brauchst du dann so einen Polizisten in einem Porsche oder so. Auf einem Gepard. Du brauchst die Gepard-Polizei. Um Gottes willen. Um Gottes willen bin ich unprofessionell, es tut mir so leid.
Nee, du brauchst eigentlich entweder Polizeigeparden, die Polizeihunde, dann kommen die Polizeigeparden, das ist so deren SEK, die Polizeihunde sind die normalen Polizisten und wenn es richtig hart kommt, dann holen die Polizeigeparden, die haben dann auch so eine schöne Sirene auf dem Kopf und die ballern dabei. Einfach für fun, eine GoPro.
Einfach eine GoPro, wo die Geschwindigkeit links unten angezeigt wird.
Wie geht das? Aber die so 70 kmh, 80 kmh, die ballern da durch die Gegend. Ja, dann 200 auf Spitzengeschwindigkeit. Oh, bergab. Boah, geil, so ein Gepard bergab einfach so. Geil, ne? So richtig schnell. Was schafft ein Gepard bergab bei Rückenwind? Ich glaube, da kommt man recht schnell in die Schallgeschwindigkeit. Also, dass die nicht abheben. Sind so Kneipengespräche? Ich nehme noch eins, Schatz. Ich nehme noch eins, Schatz? Perle, ich weiß jetzt, keine Ahnung. Perle? Wart die bei der Perle? Ich glaube, nirgendwo wäre ich so Fisch, Gepard out of the water, out of the zoo, als in der Kneipe mit zu diesen ganzen Slang-Sachen. Keine Ahnung, kenne ich mich überhaupt nicht aus. Ich auch nicht, deswegen frage ich mich, ob die sowas sagen wie Gepard, was schafft ein Gepard mit Rückenwind bergab, hä?
Boah, Mann oh Mann, Mann oh Mann, ich glaube, da kannst du den Arsch nachwerfen. Das passt nicht auf keine Kuhhaut mehr. Du, darauf trinken wir. Darauf trinken wir dran. Gläser hoch, gib doch mal einen Jäger. Ein Jäger, alles auf schwarz. Zapfenstreich, auf die Rechnung. Ach Gott, ich weiß es nicht, wirklich. Klar, wenn ich Undercover-Polizist werde, würde ich sagen, schick mich zur Comic-Con, das mache ich, alles andere falle ich sofort auf. Du weißt, du willst zu dem Ort geschickt werden, wo man dich eh erkennt als Lorentin will. Sag mal, du spielst doch hier Chaos Marines, gegen dich habe ich doch letztes gespielt. Und man sieht dein Mikrofon unter deinem Toast-Shirt. Was? Was? Nein. Du erweiterst ja deinen Horizont. Literally. Literally erweiter ich den Horizont. Quasi wörtlich. Du bist der soziale Chameleon. Ich glaube, du könntest dich überall einschleichen. Ich glaube, du könntest überall so zwei, drei. Ich meine, ich mache mich ja immer lustig über deine Phasen und drehe da deine Persönlichkeit mit Füssen. Du trittst nach unten. Es schwingt aber auch eine ganze Menge Neid mit, weil du natürlich ein sehr breites Allgemeinwissen hast. Und ich glaube, du kannst dich auch schnell in neue Felder einarbeiten. Also wenn du jetzt der Undercover-Polizist wärst, der sich jetzt mal schnell in die Rocker-Szene einarbeiten müsste, könntest du in kürzester Zeit, wie funktioniert so ein Motorrad, so eine Harley, so ein Roppet? Impeller, Motorpumpe, Öldruck, ich kenne mich da aus. Wie funktionieren diese ganzen Patches an der Lederweste, an der Kutte, wie funktioniert das alles, hey hey rock'n'roll? Ich glaube wirklich, dass ich ein soziales Chamäleon bin. Ich kann mich auf mein Gegenüber immer sehr gut einstellen. und zum Leidwesen derer, die mich schon länger begleiten in meinem Leben und mich dann beobachten, wenn ich mit anderen Leuten spreche, aus anderen Kreisen. Und das habe ich auch immer sehr grosse Angst vor, dass ich dann auffliege als jemand, der immer nur so tut, als wäre er ja so ähnlich. Als Ditto-Effekt, der sich einfach immer anpasst an die Situation. Aber wie uncool, wenn Ditto mit seinem besten Freund Pikachu rumläuft und Ditto dann plötzlich zum anderen Pokémon wird und Pikachu so, what the fuck is happening? Warum bist du nicht zu mir? Warum bist du nicht zu mir geworden? Bei dir fühle ich mich sicher, bei dir kann ich ich sein. Ja, oder du triffst einen anderen Pikachu, denkst dir, oh mein Gott, hier in dem Wald gibt es nur rechts unten in dem Vier-Mal-Vier-Feld ein paar Pikachus, ansonsten überhaupt keine, aber jetzt treffe ich endlich mal einen anderen Pikachu, stellt sich raus Ditto. Stellt sich raus ein Ditto. Ist ein Ditto in dem Moment, in dem sie sagen, hey, ich habe hier einen Donnerstein gefunden, den überlasse ich dir, damit du dich weiterentwickeln kannst, weil ich so selbstlos bin und dann drückt er dem den Donnerstein in den Bauch. Ich weiß nicht genau, was passiert, aber er drückt ihm den Donnerstein ins Gesicht. Muss man das geben? Ich glaube, du musst die Augenhöhle, du musst den Augapfel herauslöffeln. Steht nicht da der Command, shove it into his mouth. Und einfach nimm den Pikachu und den Donnerstein in den Sack und schüttel den und hau ihn dreimal gegen die Wand und dann passt es schon.
Und dann stellt sich aber raus, du, ich muss dir was sagen, ich bin kein Pikachu, ich bin Ditto. Und dann endet die erste Staffel.
Der Film.
Die erste Staffel des Films, es sind sechs Films. Es ist ein engster Song. Und es ist auch einfach Hans Zimmer in Nutshell. Und es gibt vielleicht vier Leute, die gerade mit dabei waren und alle anderen denken sich, was ist das? Ja. es ist Zeus das Breakout und wenn ihr das jetzt hören wollt, dann könnt ihr es nicht hören. Es gibt es nicht auf Spotify, es gibt irgendwie ein mitgeschnittene Fassung auf YouTube, aber sonst nichts. Und mein Klaviercover, als ich sechs war, das gibt es auch noch. Ich kann ja mal gucken, oh Gott, ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht kann ich ja mal für alle, die jetzt nicht Zeus das Breakout nicht hören, kann ich meine Garageband-Datei vielleicht nochmal raussuchen, ob ich die finde. Boah, das sind auch wirklich Sachen.
Das ist so, wie wenn man zuerst Spaceballs guckt oder halt, ja genau, oder erst die Family Guy-Parodie und dann Star Wars und bei dir ist es halt, erst das und dann Zeus' Breakout. Da habe ich mich auch letztens mit jemandem unterhalten, der dann sagte so, ja, Star Wars hat mich irgendwie nie interessiert.
Und ich so, was, du hast den Star-Wars gesehen? Ja, ich wollte mal anfangen und dann hieß es, man soll anfangen mit Episode vier und das habe ich dann angestaut. Und irgendwie fand ich das total merkwürdig, konnte ich das überhaupt nicht ernst nehmen irgendwie. Aber vielleicht war es eine Parodie, ich weiß es nicht. Was? Und ich habe mal nachgefragt und die Person hat allen Ernstes Spaceballs gesehen und dachte sich so, ey, ich verstehe, was ist das?
Weil wenn du, für uns ist es natürlich albern, weil wir kennen Star Wars, aber wenn du Star Wars wirklich gar nicht kennst und denkst, ja, vielleicht ist es ein bisschen lustig, vielleicht ist es so wie Ghostbusters und du checkst überhaupt nicht, was ist jetzt da die große, weil du verstehst ja die, Spaceballs als Star-Wars-Parodie, du verstehst ja die Witze nicht, Ghostbusters kannst du dir angucken und lachst, aber Spaceballs ja gar nicht. Und ich kann mir das so gut vorstellen, wie diese Person denkt, und das ist ein internationales Millionenphänomen. Ja, das Ding ist ja, weil diese Person geht ja mit dem Mindset in diesem Film, dass alle Menschen feiern das ab.
Genau, ja.
Heißt, und dann guckst du eine Parodie, die du nicht verstehen kannst, ohne zu wissen, dass es eine Parodie ist und denkst dir, bin ich wahnsinnig auf die Welt? Ja, genau. Oder was ist das denn? Aber wie oft mir auch so ein Quatsch passiert, dass mein Netflix noch auf italienisch eingestellt ist und man guckt einen Film und man denkt erst zehn Minuten, ah okay, ich muss gerade nichts verstehen, ich soll gerade nichts verstehen, weil ich denke, der Film ist, ich denke immer, Filme sind mir überlegen. Ja, das ist das Problem, wenn du zu viel Arthouse guckst und dich zu sehr an weirden Shit gewöhnt hast. Es für dich einfach völlig selbstverständlich ist, dass in den ersten zehn Minuten die Leute rückwärts reden und du denkst dir, ja okay, ist eine künstlerische Entscheidung, wird sich schon irgendwie auflösen oder halt nicht. Und dann, wenn du aber mal irgendwie so ein Video anguckst mit einem harten Bildfehler drin, mit einer Bildtonschere, du einfach denkst, ja, vielleicht ist das so, ein bisschen experimentell für eine Mainstream-Netflix-Serie. Und irgendwann denkst du, nee, das ist nicht experimentell, ich bin einfach nur richtig dumm. Ist mir auch immer passiert, ich habe ein sehr altes Buch irgendwann mal geliehen bekommen und habe das dann gelesen und dachte dann am Ende, krass, was das für Zeitsprünge manchmal sind, man kommt ja gar nicht hinterher und dann kommt einfach raus und dann wenn man das Buch so zusammenklappt, sieht man es auch leicht, sind einfach so seitenweise Blöcke, so Seitenblöcke raus. So ein Mängelexemplar oder was was? Ja, na ja, nee, ist einfach so ein sehr altes Buch gewesen, so ein bisschen used halt, wo einfach mal irgendwann so ein Chunk Seiten rausgefallen ist. Und wenn man halt guckt, dann die Seitenzahl, ja fehlen einfach zwölf Seiten. Und dann, ich dachte mir, das ist total spannend, so eine Art Montagetechnik, ist ja irre. Da entsteht ein neues Buch, einfach so, also toll fand ich ja, dass wirklich alles darauf abzielt, irgendwie auf dieses Treffen zwischen den beiden, die sich verliebt haben, und dann kurz bevor sie sich treffen, machen einen harten Zeitsprung, dann ist er im Gefängnis. Und es wird nie erklärt, was passiert ist. Und das fand ich total spannend. Moment, nein, doch, ich habe das doch alles geschrieben. Man spricht mit dem Autoren direkt? Okay. Ihr habt das doch alles geschrieben.
Ich habe das doch geschrieben. Wie Autoren auch reden. Ihr habt das doch alles geschrieben. Ich habe das doch geschrieben. Die waren im Drive-In und haben dann diesen Drogendeal mitverfolgt, sind hinterhergefahren und die Polizei hat fälschlicherweise die verhaftet. Nein, du hast doch diesen klasse Zeitsprung gemacht. Habe ich? Weiß ich nicht. Aber es ist schwierig. Bei mir auch und tatsächlich auch wirklich, ich bin ja immer noch in der alten Fede mit Sky, mit ihrem fucking Player, der wirklich das Letzte ist, was es gibt, der einzige Anbieter der Welt, der nochmal ein separates Programm installieren muss, indem du deine Videos schaust, anstatt es einfach im Browser zu schauen. Und da ist es oft so, wenn du die im Original guckst, also zum Beispiel bei The New Pope oder The Young Pope, da ist es ja so, die haben oft zwei, drei, drei, drei, drei, drei, drei, drei, drei zweite Staffel heisst The Young Pope. Nee, The New Pope. Nee, die erste Staffel heisst The New Pope. Nein, das ist The Young Pope. Ach, die erste Staffel Young Pope Pope, zweite Staffel, Medium Old Regular Age Pope, in his fifties, which regarding the age of all the other Popes, is quite young, but not as young as Jude Law, he was in his thirties, Pope. Also das ist die zweite Staffel und da sprechen die oft italienisch, was dann untertitelt ist, wenn du aber die Originalfassung anguckst, dann sind alle Untertitel raus, auch die, die du brauchst, wenn du Englisch verstehst. Und dann schaust du einfach minutenlang italienisch an und denkst dir einfach ja, braucht ihr mich noch? Ich dachte, das muss so sein. Ich war mir sicher bei The Young Pope, dass ich das nicht verstehen soll, dass es so, dass man die jetzt, ich dachte, clever, weil normalerweise will man das wegschneiden, wir sehen aber noch, wie sie reden, aber ich verstehe es nicht. Ich glaube, Serien und Filme sind in der Regel nicht so clever, sie sind nicht so clever, das sind einfach Fehler, das sind einfach oft Fehler. Aber es ist sehr sympathisch von uns, dass wir uns Filmen generell unterlegen füholut. Dass wir Filmen erst mal zugestehen, viel cleverer zu sein als man selbst.
Ja, ich mag das auch zum Beispiel nicht, na ja wohl, vielleicht mag ich es. Und zum Beispiel, wenn Leute sagen, wenn jetzt die neue Game of Thrones Staffel rauskommt und dann sagen Leute sowas wie, das würde Daenerys nie tun. Ja, also die denken, sie hätten die Figur besser verstanden als die Person, die das Skript geschrieben hat und sagen, eigentlich soll das anders sein. Wohingegen, wenn man jetzt mal sich so klassische Sachen anschaut, fragt man eher, warum zur Hölle verhält sich Hamlet so, wie er sich verhält? Was ist der Grund? Wie kann man das lesen und nicht, ja, das ergibt ja keinen Sinn, so würde der sich gar nicht verhalten. Ich glaube, das ist schon ein Unterschied, klar, natürlich ist Game of Thrones was anderes und mit den Büchern und blablabla ist mir klar, was du jetzt alles sagst, aber ich glaube, es gibt zwar Grundeinstellungen, ob du einmal sagst, okay, für mich sind die Handlungen vielleicht nicht ganz nachvollziehbar, interessant, warum ist das so, vielleicht hat, also gar nicht zu sagen, ich habe die Figur verstanden, es ergibt keinen Sinn, sondern aha, ich verstehe nicht, warum der das macht, dann habe ich die Figur noch nicht richtig verstanden und muss mehr reingucken. Bei Hamlet oder so, bei klassischer Literatur sagt man dann eher, warum macht der das? Ich glaube, da gab es auch einen Shift, das wollte ich nämlich jetzt sagen. Also klar kann man auch mit diesem Bücherargument kommen und Game of Thrones, glaube ich, ein besonderes Beispiel, aber man entwickelt ja, also man beobachtet ja den Trend, dass Leute mehr und mehr meinen, auch bei Star Wars zum Beispiel, bei der neuen Trilogie, ja immer sich über die Drehbuchautoren zu stellen und zu sagen, das macht alles gar keinen Sinn und nicht mehr sagen, nee, das hat mir nicht gefallen, das ist ja was anderes als zu sagen, nee, Luke Skywalker würde ja niemals so die Rebellen im Stich lassen. So, und ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass man zu sehr am Making-of-Prozess beteiligt wird, auch als Publikum. Also, dass man zu viel schon mitbekommt. Also, du hast ja gar nicht mehr diese Immersion, weil du die ganze Zeit schon das Gefühl hast, beteiligt zu werden. Du kriegst ja schon einen Teaser, wenn die Dreharbeiten starten und so. Ja, und es sind auch zu sehr Menschen. Man sieht den Drehbuchautoren und der sagt, ja, das habe ich mir so überlegt. Ich glaube früher, ich meine Shakespeare oder so, wenn du jetzt einfach im Englisch-LK so ein Buch vorgelegt bekommst, das ist halt so eine Art Gott, dieser Autor, der das halt vor hundert Jahren geschrieben hat und nicht, ah ja, das ist J.J. Abrams, ursprünglich soll es ein anderer machen, jetzt JJ Abrams hat jetzt genau zwei Wochen Zeit, sich was auszudenken und jetzt bringt er die Idee und ach naja, die ist nicht so gut. Und danach sagt er in Interviews, nee, wir hatten es jetzt so geplant und dann wird noch das Skript geleakt, von dem das erst geschrieben hat und dann sagt er, nee, aber ich mag das und das und dann, also ich glaube, man kann das ja nicht mehr so als Kunstwerk wahrnehmen, wenn diese Leute, die entlarven ja den künstlerischen Prozess total. Also was du sagst ist, Making-ofs machen, macht die Kunst, macht die Filme kaputt. Nein, der ständige Blick, die ständige Beteiligung, die gewollte Beteiligung des Publikums am Prozess, am Hinter-den-Kulissen-Prozess zerstört die Immersion. Also aber plädierst du Ignoranz, schaut euch das nicht an, oder sagst du, das soll gar nicht veröffentlicht werden? Ich bin der Meinung, manchmal sollen auch einfach Leute, die die Filme machen, die Klappe halten, sich nicht immer erklären, sich nicht immer rechtfertigen, nicht immer aufs Publikum hören und vielleicht einfach mal ab und zu den Blick hinter die Kulissen zumindest vorher sein lassen, damit man sich wieder auf die Geschichte einlassen kann. weil mittlerweile gucken viele Leute auch gar nicht mehr die Geschichte, um sich wirklich hineinzuversetzen in die Welt. Ich glaube, viele gucken Avengers Endgame oder so nicht, um sich dann da in die Welt fallen zu lassen, sondern um den Film zu bewerten im Kontext der Reihe. So, keine Ahnung. Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, das wird irgendwie gerade
gewollt und so ein bisschen hervorgerufen.
Und es soll mal wieder weg, es soll mal wieder
in Richtung, man soll sich mal wieder fallen lassen.
Mal wieder das Licht ausmachen, um mal wieder
in dem Film die Welt zu betreten.
Sich mal wieder so richtig in so einem Tim und
Struppi-Comic zu verlieren, wirklich keine Ahnung,
wann wurde das geschrieben, von wem,
keine Ahnung, sich einfach fallen lassen.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wer wer ist. Einfach so, als das... Wahrscheinlich ist Struppi der Hund. Aber gut. So wie die Bibel halt, wo du wirklich nicht genau weißt, wer ist hier der Autor, wen soll ich angeben als Autor, wer ist der Lieblingsautor? Gab es mal die Bibel, B-E-E-B-L-E, die Bibel, alles aus Sicht der Bienen? Alle Erwähnungen von Bienen innerhalb der Bibel? Nee, ich dachte eher so deren Religion. Alles was aus der Bienensicht passiert ist in der Zeit, wo diese ganzen Bibelsachen passiert sind. The Bibel. Wie lange liegt das? Finde ich gut. Oder halt The Bibel, also die B-Bibel. The Bibel. Die B-Seite, die Excenate Edition, rausgeschnittene Sachen. Aber es ist spannend, ich habe letztes Video geguckt von Wer ist der Autor der Bibel? Und da gibt es ja verschiedene Theorien, wann was zuerst geschrieben wurde und was dann hinzugefügt wurde und so. Und ganz spannend auf jeden Fall. Aber da ist es auch so. Den besten machen sollte. Ein bisschen wie bei J.J. Abrams in Star Wars. Genau, aber wegen kreativen Differenzen mit Isaac wurde dann rausgeschmissen und es wurde nochmal komplett umgeschrieben.
Er hat sich später distanziert und hat gesagt, ich habe doch nicht geschrieben von sieben dünnen Kühen. Wie langweilig ist das denn? Und dann wurde J.J. Abraham genommen und J.J. Abraham hat dann gesagt, ich mache das, aber zu meinen Under My Terms. Genau, und er musste sich aber ganz strikt an die Vorgabe von Georg Lukas halten, der eigentlich gesagt hat, dass die Figuren sich nur in gewisse Richtungen entwickeln dürfen. Und es ist ein Riesenkonglomerat letzten Endes geworden, von daher hätte ich aber auch mal Bock. Aber immer Georg Lukas mit seinem Goliath, ne? Dieser Comic-Relief-Charakter, dieser grosse Troll. Ja, das ist lächerlich, wirklich lächerlich. Ich finde ohnehin die Comic Reliefs in der Bibel ein bisschen drüber.
Ich glaube, da sind auch viele Gags.
Komödische Reliefs sagt man, glaube ich, in der Bibel.
Ja, ja, aber das finde ich ist auch ein gutes Buch, Comedy in der Bibel.
Weil ich glaube, da liegen Gags und nicht im Sinne von haha, wie dumm sind die, dass die nicht erst, weil wenn der am zweiten Tag die Sonne macht, wie hat er am ersten
Tag dann was gesehen, haha, lol, nicht so, sondern im Sinne von was ist
Vielen Dank. Ernst gemeinte Gags. Dass sie nicht erst, weil wenn der am zweiten Tag die Sonne macht, wie hat er am ersten Tag dann was gesehen? Haha, lol. Nicht so, sondern im Sinne von, was ist da drin, was wir heute nicht mehr als Gag verstehen? Wie bei Shakespeare, wo ja auch ganz viele Gags drin sind, die du heute einfach nicht verstehen kannst, weil du die Anspielungen nicht verstehst, weil die machen da Witze über Dinge, die passiert sind letzte Woche, da ist irgendjemand vom Pferd gefallen, irgendein Adliger, und die machen Gag und die lachen sich kaputt. Und heute Frage, was sind Pferde? Englische K. lesen, what? Wir verstehen nichts. Was ist daran lustig, vom Pferd zu fallen? Ja, mal wirklich so ein Buch, wo es extrem trocken, extrem, also wirklich so im Wüstensand, alle Gags in der Bibel erklärt werden und was daran lustig war. Und ich glaube, da kann man sich schon so ein bisschen durchgegeln. Extrem trocken, aber der Titel ist sehr reisserisch, irgendwie so Roffels in der Bibel oder so. Genau, ja. Ja, Pogs in der Bibel. Finde ich gut. Wolltest du gerade fragen, wie lang, wie alt Bienen werden? Ich war dabei zu fragen, weil ich weiß genau die Antwort, weil ich es lustigerweise gerade nachgelesen habe. Ah, super. Und zwar, die Bienenkönigin wird vier bis sieben Jahre, drei bis vier Jahre alt, glaube ich. Was? So alt? In dem Spektrum, ich habe es nicht genau gemerkt. Drei bis sieben Jahre alt.
Das ist aber ...
Ich glaube, drei bis vier Jahre alt.
Und das hat stark mit dem Cholesterin zu tun?
Oder woran hängt das, wie alt zu dem?
Ich habe es eh ... Ich fand das so interessant.
Ich bin heute bei Twitter über ein TikTok-Video von einer Bienenkämpferin.
Also eine Frau in Texas, die für die Bienen verlegt. Die kämpft für Bienen. Ach so. Die verlegt, wenn irgendwo, keine Ahnung, irgendwas Bienenbefallen ist, verlegt sie die Beehives zu sich oder woanders hin, wo sie dann safe leben können. Also Entführung.
Die entführt Bienenstämme. Und das ist total spannend. Da fand ich es mir so krass, wie die dann die Königin sucht und die dann so wegnimmt und dann woanders hinbringt. Und dann folgt der ganze Schwarm dieser Königin. Und die Königin ist ja viel grösser. Und ich fand das alles faszinierend, dachte mir, wie ist es überhaupt möglich, weil es gibt ja
es gibt männliche Bienen,
die drohen, es gibt weibliche Bienen,
die Arbeiterinnen und es gibt die Bienenkönigin
und wenn ein Stamm
zu gross wird, züchten
die eine zweite Königin heran,
die dann wegfliegt und die Hälfte
des Stammes mitnimmt.
Wie ist das möglich?
Das ist schon krass, die haben ein drittes Geschlecht. Ja, aber wie entscheiden die, wer die Königsbiene wird? Ja, die entscheiden, wenn sie eine brauchen, dann wird die nämlich mit dem Gelee-Royal, mit einem anders hergestellten Honig gefüttert. Und dadurch bilden sie sich dann die ... Das ist faszinierend. Ich glaube, das ist eine andere Hormonsufuhe oder sowas, keine Ahnung, jedenfalls ist das die einzig fruchtbare weibliche Biene im Stamm. Moment, aber ich meine, wir sind Menschen, wir können nicht anders als Tieren alles wegzunehmen, was sie haben. Hat ein Mensch jemals dieses Gelee Royale gegessen? Hat sich schön auf eine Stulle gesch Stulle gespielt. Hitler mal gesagt, so, weg mit den Würstchen. Wäre viel besser, wenn ich so Flügel hätte. Können wir das nicht mal? Hat kein Mensch mit Grössen Wahn und sehr viel Macht in der Geschichte der Menschheit jemals mal ausprobiert, ob nicht wir Menschen auch dieses dritte Geschlecht, den Menschenkönig oder Menschenköniginnen herstellen können. Weil wenn du grösser wirst und besser und irgendwie anders riechst oder so, du veränderst ja alles. Oder ist es einfach nur, was ist da drin, was ist dieses Chili Royale und warum kann ich es nicht bestellen in so ein Glas und es einfach mir schön morgens aufs Brot schmieren? Und warum klingt das so geil? Es klingt grossartig, es klingt lecker, es klingt wirklich lecker. Und es klingt nach einer geilen Band. Es klingt nach einer geilen Band. Und klingt auch nach einem mittelmässigen Superhelden, Bienenmann, Beeman. Ja, geile Band, schlechter Film. Geleemann, der halt genau die Idee hat, so einen Hobby- Imker, ähm, genau, der Hobby-Imker, der sich immer so sehr für seine Bienen einsetzt, dass die Bienen irgendwann, wenn sie eine neue Königin sich für ihn entscheiden und sagen, du hast uns immer geholfen, du hast uns gerettet vor diesem Jungen. Irgendwann steht so ein Gelee-Royal-Kelch-Räum und er nimmt es, die Bienen geben es ihm, reichen es an, die fliegen immer weg an so einen Ort und er weiss nicht wohin. Irgendwann geht er da hin und merkt, die Bienen haben ihm Gelee-Royal für die Masse eines Menschen gemacht und irgendwo in so eine Kokosnussschale gelegt. Er geht ums Haus, trinkt aus der Kokosnussschale dieses Gelee Royale und wird The Bee Man. Ja, wird Bee King. Der König, der erste König der Bienen. Und dann kommt aber raus, das Ganze spielt im Spider-Man-Universum. Und er fliegt in so eine Spinnenweben rein. Und er fliegt los und wird einfach Bee-Man. Er wird auch böse, weil er nur noch für die Bienen Sachen macht. Ja, müssen wir mal gucken, ob der dann, also entweder er wird dann auch so wie Ant-Man ganz klein oder er ist eine grosse, das Problem ist an Bienen, sie sind halt so niedlich mit diesem flauschigen Fell, dieses Tiger-Giraffen-Fell, so ein bisschen pummelig. Ich glaube, B-Man ist einfach nicht so ernst zu nehmen. Als Spider-Man, Spinnen sind viel cooler. Ich glaube auch und ich glaube auch, dass du die mit Hummel verwechselst. Ja, kann gut sein. Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, Unterschied zwischen Biene, Hummel, Wespe, Bremse, für mich alles dasselbe, das ist alles das gleiche. Oh, kann ich dir erklären, Bremsen sind einfach nur nicht so schön gestreift, haben keine schönen Farben. Wespen sind die nackten, aggressiven Varianten von Bienen. Aber ich glaube nicht unbedingt minder wichtig für den Kreislauf. Die sind alle wichtig, jeder spielt seine Rolle. Du kannst nicht einfach sagen, ein Insekt muss weg. Ganz im Ernst, ich glaube doch, wenn ich ganz ehrlich mal sein soll. Es ist die Wahrheit, in die wir blicken können, manche Tiere sind nützlich, andere einfach nicht. Ja, ich glaube, manche Tiere sind scheißegal für den Kreislauf, für The Circle of Life. Es ist eher kein Circle, es ist eher wie ein Ü. Also es gibt ein grosses U, in dem alle beteiligt sind, und dann gibt es aber auch Punkte, die ausserhalb sind. The Ü of Life. Manche stehen einfach ausserhalb. Nee, es ist ein Ö. Es ist ein Ö. The Ö of Life. Klar, natürlich gibt es einen Kreis. Natürlich. Aber es gibt auch einfach die Schnecke, die draußen ist, so mit
so einem, ah, wo komme ich rein,
wie wenn du dich einordnest
beim Verkehr, so, wie komme ich jetzt in diesen Kreis,
ach, wisst ihr was, ich nehme die Landstrasse.
Und man auch so merkt, oh, das ist ja schon ein Kreis,
ohne mich. Richtig. Ich blicke ja von außen
auf einen perfekt funktionierenden Kreislauf.
Genau. Warum brauchst du mich als Schnecke da?
Ha, hoffentlich merkt es niemand, schnell
in mein Haus. Genau, braucht niemand,
ich störe eigentlich nur, man weiß nicht genau,
wie man es ausspricht, klar, es wäre einfacher
Vielen Dank. Genau. Warum brauchst du mich als Schnecke da? Ha, hoffentlich merkt es niemand schnell in mein Haus. Genau, braucht niemand. Ich störe eigentlich nur. Man weiß nicht genau, wie man es ausspricht. Klar, es wäre einfacher zu zeichnen. Für jeden Typografen ist die Ö erstmal ein Riesenproblem. Es wäre besser, wenn es ein O wäre. Also es gibt Tiere, ich sage nicht, dass die weg müssen, mein Gott. Ich sage doch nicht, dass die jetzt alle systematisch verfrachtet und zerdrückt werden müssen in einer grossen Insektenpresse, die wir auf dem Marktplatz aufstellen. Und jeder, der ein Kilo unliebsame Insekten mitbringt, kriegt dafür irgendwie Zuckerwatte. Gelee Royale. Genau, das Gelee Royale, das aus denen verarbeitet wird, das sag ich doch nicht. Aber auch da die Frage an dich, du bist ja kulinarisch begabt, Insekten essen, viele sagen es ist die Zukunft, viele sagen es ist ekelhaft, was sagst du? Ich hatte mir neulich mal, weil es in meinem Supermarkt gab es Heuschrecken, geröstete Heuschrecken im Snackregal und ich habe gesagt, ja natürlich, warum nicht mal ausprobieren? Super, gut, weil dies gibt es sehr viel, es ist sehr gut, glaube ich, herzustellen. Sorry, dir ist schon klar, dass Heuschrecken wörtlich eine Plage sind, die das Ende der Zeit einleitet. Ja. Und du gehst ins Snackregal, also nur einmal die Hybris, hier auch nochmal anzukratzen, du gehst ins Snackregal und holst dir eine Tüte Heuschrecken. Ich habe gedacht, wenn man eine Plage zu essen machen kann, dann haben wir alle Probleme gelöst. Dann machen wir aus dem Ö of Life ein kleines Ö of Life, nämlich so eine Art Abkürzung. Das ist doch wie, wir lösen einfach alle Probleme. Wir lösen alle Probleme, wenn plötzlich, und das ist wie so eine Abkürzung, wenn man aus einer Plage, die uns Gott geschickt hat, um die zu vernichten. Wenn man live gibt es eine Plage, mach Snacks draus, denke ich mir, das ist eigentlich die brillante Lösung. Und wenn mir das schmeckt, dann bin ich ein aktiver Teil, um diese Welt zum besseren Ort zu machen. Aber das ist die ganze Heuschrecke oder nur ein Teil? Nee, du kannst die Umrisse des Tieres klar erkennen. Und die sind frittiert dann oder so paniert? Ja, so gebraten, so geil gebraten. Ja, wie so Laugen, diese Laugensnacks, die einfach kurz gebraten sind. Wahrscheinlich in Öl gebraten, wahrscheinlich frittiert. Und die haben dir geschmeckt? Null, super eckig. Wonach schmecken die? Ja, also es riecht schon so nach Fischfutter und es schmeckt auch so ein bisschen so, wie man sich... Fischfutter? Ja. Sorry, ich meine, du bist mittlerweile in anderen Sphären unterwegs, aber ich kann mir da nichts darunter vorstellen. Nein, es riecht so ein bisschen wie Fischfutter. Niemand in der Nase Fischfutter genommen? Nein, noch nie. Ich hatte nie was mit Fischen zu tun gehabt. Also zum einen Katzenfutter kenne ich. Meine Mom hat einen Teich bei sich, deswegen habe ich da auch viel mit Fischfutter zu tun gehabt. Ansonsten natürlich durch meine Fischvergangenheit und jetzt als Seefahrer bin ich natürlich mit Fischfutter bestens vertraut. Aber es riecht so, wie man sich getrocknete Insekten vorstellt. Und jetzt ist es auch irgendwie schwer, dass ich da rauskomme aus diesem Kreis. Also es ist irgendwie so ein bisschen so ein, es bedingt sich gerade alles selber und irgendwie musst du da jetzt einen Zugang finden. Aber ja, weiß ich nicht, so ein bisschen modrig, erdig. Aber wie kriegt man das hin, das Image von Insekten zu verbessern? Weil das ist ja eine kulturelle Sache.
The Bible.
Müsste man da nicht einfach irgendwie, also ich weiß nicht, reicht da so eine Plakatkampagne oder so, Leckermaden oder irgendwie sowas, ich weiß nicht, welcher Promi angefragt wird. So, äh, Hugo, wir hätten eine tolle Plakatkampagne für dich. Egon Balder?
Ja, wir hätten eine gute Plakatkampagne für dich, und zwar du, Kölner Hauptbahnhof, riesengroß, ja? Ja. Erstmal, wie findest du das? Finde ich mega, richtig geil, wofür? Und dann da halt noch so ein fetziger Spruch drunter, ja, also wirklich was Lustiges, die Leute verbinden dich mit verrückten Ideen, mit obskuren Geschichten, mit tollen Gags irgendwie.
Sowas in der Richtung, sowas wie Lecker-Maden. Maden, lecker und du hast den Mund voll Maden. Also wir reden jetzt nicht über so eine Ekel-Kampagne, sondern einfach um das Image zu verbessern. Lecker Maden und dann Hugo Egon Made oder irgendwie sowas. Also irgendwie wirklich, dass du so voller,
also das Gesicht, also wirklich,
die schmecken dir so gut, dass du um deinen Mund herum Fühler und
und und und
Herr Balder, Herr Egon Balder,
Bugo Egon Alder,
Helgo Bugon Elder,
oh, na gut.
Aber irgendwas, ich weiß nicht, was es
da braucht, falls ihr Promi seid und das Image von Insekten. Weil vor allem das Problem ist. Muss es denn besser werden? Naja, heißt es nicht, dass wir alle verhungern, wenn wir nicht anfangen Insekten zu essen oder so? Habe ich mal in einem Comic. Aber ich denke mir so, in einem Comic von der Geoline gelesen. Aber ernst im Ernst, warum nicht einfach so schön in so ein Glas Senf oder in so eine, oder Kräuterbutter? Oder in Salat, so statt den Croutons oder sowas. Oder so Gewürz, Ketchup, was alle wollen immer. Es gibt auch so ein paar Sachen, die, oh, so soll der jetzt jetzt zur Spargelzeit auch genau das Gleiche, was ich meine. Es gibt so ein paar Beilagen, die übertünchen das Essen. Die sind lauter, geschmackslauter als das Essen an sich. Wenn man da jetzt einfach so eine Nährstoffhalte, Mineralstoff, Proteinhaltige Made in so ein Senfglas fallen lässt oder schön Kräuterbutter oder sowas. Und dann halt so ein bisschen dieses Madenbutter, das ist eine gute Idee. Die Butter übertüncht eh alles. Einfach ab jetzt ist in jeder Kräuterbutter, und das müssen wir gesetzlich festhalten,
damit nicht irgendwie einer da aus der Reihe tanzt, in jeder Kräuterbutter ist ein Prozent Made.
Und ich glaube, wenn du das erstmal ein paar Jahre durchziehst und die Leute nicht anders können,
als sie Kräuterbutter zu kaufen, wenn der ein Prozent Made ist und sich irgendwann denkt.
Aber es gibt natürlich, I can't believe it's not maden.
Das gibt es nicht schon.
Die dann irgendwann sagen, ich könnte mir eigentlich Made nicht mehr wegdenken aus der Kräuterbutter. Plötzlich ist es irgendwie in jedem Froop, in jedem Fruchtjoghurt hast du ein Prozent Heuschrecke. Aber wir wollen ja nicht töten, wir wollen ja irgendwas aus dem Joghurt ersetzen. Du bist gerade einfach all in Richtung, wir killen Insekten gegangen. Ja, aber wir müssen es ja essen. Du willst erst mal die Menschen daran gewöhnen. Darum geht es ja erst mal. Die Menschheit sich langsam daran zu gewöhnen, dass sie irgendwann darauf umsteigen können. Weil die Idee ist ja, Dinge zu ersetzen, die ökologisch schwierig sind oder sowas, durch halt dieses Überangebot an Heuschrecken. Ja, einfach die Horizontarbeit und einfach so ein bisschen mehr Auswahl, damit man dann wieder andere Sachen runter regulieren kann. Irgendwann einfach so, einfach mal, jede Eisdiele hat ein Käffereis. So, das ist billiger als alle anderen. Und das ist dann so unter Jugendlichen, haha, cool, wenn du traust dich nicht, wenn du traust dich nicht, äh, äh, und Probe, boah, kratz, boah, ey, der nimmt es, äh, geil, cool, äh, lass es noch dann zum Skatepark gehen und Fortnite spielen. So, ich bin neulich mit dem Fahrrad gefahren und dann bin ich an einem Skatepark vorbeigekommen. Geil. Aber ich bin da kurz hingesetzt, weil das war so ein Riesenskatepark im Köln am Rhein, wo ganz viele Menschen drumherum saßen und haben den Skater, den coolen Kids zugeguckt beim Skaten. Und es ist ein bisschen wie so eine Brunftzeit beim Menschen, so ein bisschen. Ja. So Ballsverhalten. Halt ganz viele Menschen in der Mitte haben Kunststücke aufgeführt, die sich Leute draußen eingeguckt haben. Und ab und zu sind dann Menschen aus der Mitte auch dann nach außen gegangen, um sich Paarungspartner zu finden. Und ich habe mich ein bisschen gefühlt wie so ein Dokumentationssprecher. Und jetzt findet er sein Weibchen, was ihm gefällt. Oh, der 360 hat dem Weibchen gut gefallen. Der Olli scheint ihr imponiert zu haben. So, und dann gucken wir halt rum und ich dachte die ganze Zeit, die sind alle cool. Und da ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass die 90er jetzt vollends zurück sind, modetechnisch, die 90er sind zurück. Wahrscheinlich sind sie schon seit ein paar Jahren zurück, aber damit, ihr hört das Podcast-Ufwe jetzt auch nicht, um tagesaktuelle Motivtipps zu kommen. Davon würde ich euch auch abraten. Davon würde ich auch abraten, nur, falls ihr es jetzt mal mitbekommen, noch nicht mitbekommen habt, die 90er sind zurück. Klettverschluss ist zurück, Jojo ist zurück. Es sind, Mittelteitel ist zurück, versuche ich auch selber jetzt gerade. Klappt noch nicht ganz, müssen Haare noch wachsen, es sind die weiteren Hosen zurück, Skinny Jeans, lasst die Skinny Jeans zu Hause, packt die Skinny Jeans in den Altkleiderbeutel, ihr wollt wieder die weiteren Hosen haben. Dann die Converse, die Chucks können wieder rausholen. Hoffentlich habt ihr sie behalten, denn sie sind wieder ready für die Outside World.
Dann halt so 90er-Shirts, typische 90er-Shirts, ich weiß nicht, wie man es schreiben soll, alte Vintage-Shirts. Aber was ich mir denke, ich glaube, ich bin noch gespannt auf die Fusion der Jugendkultur mit dem aktuellen Überangebot von Elektromobilität. Ich denke an die Roller. Es sind ein paar Roller, auch umgefahren. Ja, warum ist der Skatepark nicht dominiert von Leuten, die einfach mit
voller Geschwindigkeit mit ihrem Elektroroller
über die Halfpipe ballern? Sind ein paar
lange ballert. Aber ist das nicht extrem gefährlich?
Weil, denen ist es ja egal, wenn
das Ding kaputt geht, das ist ja nicht ihr eigenes.
Wo du selbst, weil früher hat bei uns irgendwann auch
jemand mal ein Moped, wo wir gesagt haben, Alter, geil,
lass uns schön durch den Wald ballern, irgendwie eine
Sprungschanze bauen, und der hat gesagt, wow, wow, wow, ich habe gerade mein ganzes Vermögen ausgegeben für dieses Moped, nein. Mit großer Geschwindigkeit kommt grosse Verantwortung. Richtig, und da kannst du ja sagen, wenn du das mietest, kannst du ja, also ich würde einfach mal durch den Wald ballern mit so einem, also ich rede jetzt nicht von diesen City-Rollern, E-Rollern, sondern von den Vespa, Elektro-Vespa-Rollern, die so 50 kmh fahren können, mit dem einfach mal so durch den Wald ballern, über den Wald oder damit irgendwie mal so einen Kreisel antreiben oder über die Halfpipe. Ich denke mir, warum sind da nicht einfach jetzt die Krankenhäuser voll mit Genickbrüchen von jungen Leuten, die mit den Elektro-Waggons durch die Gegend rasen, wetzen? Meine grösste Heldin da war ein ganz kleines Mädchen, weil das waren vor allem halt ältere Jungs, so 21 rum, und da war ein ganz kleines Mädchen dabei, auf Inlinern, und wir bestimmt, keine Ahnung, sechs oder sowas, Helm auf, alles voller Schoner, also mehr Schoner als Mädchen, und ist dann da rumgefahren zwischen den ganzen harten Jungs im Balz-Mode mit krassen, trendigen Sachen, ist hier einfach rumgefahren, hat einfach versucht, inlernen zu lernen. Und ich habe mir gedacht, wie geil, weil wie mutig ist das denn? Hätte ich nie als Kind nie gemacht. Ich hätte so viel Angst gehabt vor diesen ganzen fremden Menschen. Ich habe heute noch Angst vor Jugendlichen, wirklich. Ja, ich auch. Also nicht Angst, aber Respekt.
Nee, ich auch. Ich habe wirklich Angst.
Ich habe wirklich Angst.
Ich würde nie, nie irgendwie hingehen und nach der Uhrzeit fragen oder sowas. Never ever. Ich würde eher verhungern, als die zu fragen, ob ich kurz ein Handy benutzen darf. Ich habe immer noch, ich weiß nicht, was es ist an Jugendlichen, aber irgendwie habe ich immer noch großen Respekt. Die sind cool, die sind so cool. Die sind so cool. Und dann saß ich da und hab die alle an mir angeguckt und die waren alle so cool und so bewusst gekleidet und so.
Und ich dachte mir, das Einzige, was ich dachte, weil es war so viel Sonne, die sind nicht eingecremt wahrscheinlich. Und das hat mir so ein bisschen Genugtuung gegeben. Und du hattest zufällig Sonnencreme dabei. Und hab den allen angeboten, die ganzen Menschen einzucremen. Nein, ich hab nur gedacht, das hat mir so ein bisschen Genugtuung verschafft, dass die alle Sonnenbrand haben werden wollen. Die sind zwar cool und die haben Sex, aber die sind dafür halt alle Sonnenbrand nicht eingecremt, dachte ich mir. Die sind alle nicht eingecremt. Und vielleicht hilft euch das, wenn ihr an so einer Horde cooler Leute vorbeikommt, zu denken, die sind nicht eingecremt. Und weißt du was, ich glaube, die meisten von denen haben auch keine vernünftige Hausratsversicherung.
Aber ich schon.
Ja.
Und ich persönlich nicht, aber viele Leute, die es vielleicht sehen, denken.
Aber ich weiss, dass ich es bräuchte.
Genau.
Die wissen auch nicht mal, wie sehr sie Versicherungen bräuchten. Ich schon.
Also, liebe Leute, nichts ist sexier als Selbstreflexion.
Ja. Als seine eigenen Fehler kennen. Und eigencremes zu sein. Schön glänzend, ganz weisses Gesicht. Ich meine, jetzt mal ganz kurz, muss Sonnencreme denn unbedingt so wahnsinnig weiss sein? Kann man das nicht in verschiedenen Hauttönen anbieten, dass man nicht einfach aussieht wie ein fucking Clown, also wirklich wörtlich wie ein Clown, weil ich glaube viele, du hast es schon gesagt, viele Jugendliche erleiden massive UV-Krankheiten aufgrund von Uncoolness der Sonnencreme. Muss die so weiss sein? Das weiss ich nicht. Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, es gibt auch Transparente mittlerweile. Ich glaube, da musst du halt auch mal ein bisschen tiefer ins Portemonnaie greifen oder vielleicht ins Regal der Sonnencremes. Oder können wir nicht in sämtliches Make-up auch diese Anti-UV-Sachen rechnen? Das ist aber glaube ich sogar so. In allen, also wirklich in allen? In vielen, was man so benutzen kann, ist glaube ich auch schon UV-Schutz drin. Echt? Das heißt, die klassische Sonnencreme werden wir langsam verabschieden müssen. Es gibt auch so Feuchtigkeitscreme und so, auch bestimmt für dich in deinem DM um die Ecke oder Rossmann. Das ist nett, dass auch mein Privat-DM beliefert wird. Auch in ihrem DM, sag mal noch. Da findest du bestimmt auch eine Feuchtigkeitscreme, die du eh benutzen kannst. Aber meinst du nicht, dass ich, also wie gesagt, ich will jetzt nicht die Verschwörungstheorien aufmachen, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da der Rossmann, Herr dm und Doktor Schlecker zusammensitzen und sagen, natürlich könnten wir alles, was die Menschen brauchen, in einer Creme zusammenfassen. Aber lass uns doch fünf verschiedene Produkte draus machen und die alle für drei Euro neunzehnt. Wir werden doppelcheuern, aber das machen. Natürlich könnten wir in Make-up auch automatisch Feuchtigkeitscreme und Sonnencreme und alles dazu nehmen. Natürlich können wir Shampoo und Antischuppen und Varnish, Oxy Action, natürlich könnten wir das alles zusammen mixen, aber das machen wir nicht. Natürlich könnte das, was man in die Spülmaschine tut, genau das gleiche selbe, was man in die Waschmaschine packt. Naja, natürlich könnte die Zahnpasta genau dasselbe sein, mit dem man die Waschmaschine entkalkt. Na klar, das kann alles dasselbe sein. Und das kann auch deine Zahnpasta sein, aber wer wären wir denn, wir wären doch bescheuert. Natürlich, du musst doch deine, sonst kaufst du dir doch keine Sonnencreme extra für deine Zähne mehr. Das kann doch alles dasselbe sein. Im Grunde könnten wir unseren Laden ersetzen durch einen so riesigen Spender, wo du wirklich draufdrückst für fünf Euro auf so einen grossen Knopf und dann kommt so ein Liter Soße, zack, raus und da ist alles drin. Das ist Gelee Royale. Oh ja, das kann sein. Plot twist, wenn man alles ... Gelee Royale. Hast du mal eine Biene mit Sonnenbrand gesehen? Ich nicht. Ich behaupte ... Aber auch nie Karies? Noch nie Karies gesehen? Wir werden irgendwann, in 100 Jahren wird man diese Folge hören und sagen, they knew it all along. Wenn man all das zusammenpackt und diese eine Creme macht, die alles kann, erhält man Gelee Royale. Und wenn du davon isst, wirst und wenn du davon isst, bist du zum Menschenkönig. Und du brauchst nur noch das. Und damit machst du die Fenster sauber, du putzt dir die Zähne, alles, alles ist da drin, Abfluss, alles ist in dieser Einfluss. Und du bist halt auch dann vier Meter gross, das ist halt auch okay. Das ist halt auch nebenbei, ja, das stimmt. Und du kriegst, ich weiß nicht, ob du Flügel kriegst. Kann die Königin denn noch fliegen oder ist die zu schwer?
Nein, kann fliegen.
Das heißt, die kriegt auch größere Flügel oder was? Oder mehr Flügel, wie so ein Helikopter, der zwei Rotoren hat, so ein Transporthelikopter. Die haben vorne und hinten Flügelpaare und man muss sich vorstellen, wie diese grossen amerikanischen Militärhelikopter. Helikopter, wie cool, das ist auch immer verrückt, oder? Kann mir keiner erzählen, dass Helikopter, die fliegen teilweise in Panzer mit so einem Helikopter rum. Ich denke mir, hat das jemand durchgerechnet? Hat da mal jemand einfach Excel aufgemacht und da auch mal so was wie Luftwiderstand eingerechnet? Sorry, ich will jetzt nicht euren Traum zerstören, aber irgendwie so was wie Rotationsgeschwindigkeit, Reibung, hat da mal jemand drauf geguckt?
Ich glaube nicht, was mir auch jetzt klar geworden ist beim Führerschein machen für Segelboot und Motorboot,
dass wenn du ein Segelboot hast, was Rückenwind hat, je schneller es wird, desto mehr Wind bekommst du ja auch von vorne an Fahrtwind,
was das Schiff wieder bremst. Um dann wieder stehen zu bleiben. Um dann wieder stehen zu bleiben. Und dann geht es wieder los. Das ist der nervigste Circle der Welt. Wie kacke ist das denn? Deswegen will Jan Segelboot auch nicht Wind von hinten haben, sondern eher so von Schrägachttern, damit du so leicht am Wind fahren kannst.
Aber das ist schon lustig,
also dass natürlich dann irgendwann
der Fahrtwind von vorne,
die schneller du wirst, zum nervigsten
Problem wird und dich halt ausbrennt.
Ja, das, was dich antreibt, hält dich auch zurück.
Ist das die Moral von Segelfahren?
Das ist meine Metapher.
Was mich antreibt, hält mich aber auch zurück.
Okay, und wann verwendest du die?
Weiß ich noch nicht. Noch nicht, aber du hast sie in der Hintergrund. Das ist gerade zum ersten Mal aufgekommen. Wie läuft es denn? Hast du die Prüfung bestanden? Bestanden! Bestanden, herzlichen Glückwunsch! Mit null Fehlern bestanden. Bestanden. Du musstest eine Flasche rumächsen, dreimal Landratte sagen und was noch? Und Drink Up Me Hardys singen. Okay, und das hast du geschafft. Ja, Glückwunsch. Ich heisst doch Drink Up Me Hardys. Aber hast du den Lappen jetzt? Herzchen singt Jigs Barrow Drink Up. Wie erinnert der Song noch mal? Ich erinnere mich nur noch an Yoho. Yoho, ja, das ist der Song, ich weiss nicht mehr. Aber hast du den Lappen jetzt? Nee, ich muss noch die praktische Prüfung machen, aber theoretisch habe ich jetzt bestanden. Glückwunsch. Und der Priefer hat gesagt, Herr Tietze, Sie haben beide Teile bestens bestanden. Och, herrlich. So ein ernster Seebär und der hat sich gefreut, bis hinzukriegt. Ist auch einer durchgeflogen, einer ist durchgefallen vor mir, der hatte acht Fehlerpunkte, das darfst du nicht haben. Aber es war sehr süß, da zu sehen. Er ist über die Planke gegangen. Der wurde dann auf eine Planke geschickt und musste dann aus dem dritten Stock. Wurde er geworfen. Die Kiel holt. Und wir haben gerufen alle. Danny Jones wird dich holen! Der Kraken! Herr Tietze, bitte. Psst, ich schreibe mir nur mal hier die Prüfung. Entschuldigung. Ich fand es aber sehr süß, wie dann alle saßen mit ihren mitgebrachten Geodreiecken und Zirkeln und waren dann da sehr durchmixte, superdiverse, altersdiverse, geschlechterdiverse Gruppe an Menschen, die dann da saßen und halt mit Zirkelchen und Geodreiecken dann die Kurse von Helgoland nach Wangerooge berechnen mussten. Aber gibt's da einen kurzen Smalltalk davor, oder wie ist das ganz, ganz stirben?
Ich kam gleich zu spät, ehrlich gesagt, ich hab nicht viel gehört an Smalltalk, ich kam zu spät an und dann ist er direkt in Medias Reis gegangen, hat gesagt, in Medias Sees gegangen, hat sofort gesagt, ja hier, jetzt bitte Namen drauf schreiben und für manche, es gibt zwei Zettel für manche einen, ich habe ja direkt zwei Prüfungen, aber sofort bin und sehe gleichzeitig abgelegt.
Und kam da nochmal so ein bisschen als Schulprüfungsangstgefühl hoch? Natürlich, ich war, ich könnte davor nicht gut schlafen, ich war so nervös, dabei ist es gar nicht so schwierig und ich war auch gut vorbereitet, aber es war natürlich trotzdem, ich bin ein Prüfungs-Chester wirklich, ich habe wirklich Angst vor Prüfungen. Und dieses Gefühl, da zu sitzen auf diesen separierten Tischen mit nichts weiter als dem Kugelschreiber und dem Kopf, ist einfach angsteinflösend.
Vor allem der Prüfer und dann gibt man das ab und der korrigiert sofort.
Es gibt 15 verschiedene Bögen und für alle die Lösungen vor sich liegen und korrigiert dann sofort durch und sagt einem sofort, ob man bestand oder nicht.
Und muss dann da kurz daneben stehen, während der einmal da durchrattert.
Und du musst kurz daneben stehen, ja. Super unangenehm, aber hat alles best funktioniert. Und ich bin jetzt bereit. Ich habe bald meine erste Praxisstunde, bin ich zum ersten Mal beim Wasser so richtig. Wow. Und dann habe ich bald auch die praktische Prüfung. Und ich fange jetzt bereits nebenbei anzulernen für den richtigen krassen Segelschein, den SKS, den Sportküsten Schifferschein. Das ist sozusagen, da kann man auch sogar gewerblich dann mit Segelboote fahren. Wer fährt gewerblich Segelboote? Kannst du dann so einen Sneaker von einem Hafen zum anderen fahren? Oder wie funktioniert das? Du kannst auch andere Menschen, du kannst auch deine Skipper-Fertigkeiten anbieten als Captain. Und darf man grillen auf dem Boot? Man darf natürlich grillen auf dem Boot. Darf man grillen? Ich glaube, man darf grillen auf dem Boot. Also Feuer machen auf der See ist erlaubt. Kein offenes Feuer, nein. Das ist ja dumm. Aber grillen? Ja, grillen ist glaube ich okay. Feuerwerk? Darf man eine Rakete abschießen? Aber ich wollte nur mal sagen, also an die Schwabenintelligenz da draußen, habt ihr ein SKS gemacht oder plant plant den dieses Jahr noch zu machen, oder habt ihr Empfehlungen, weil das nicht so einfach, da muss man dann wirklich, ich bräuchte ja dann auch, man braucht 300 Seemeilen, muss man zurückgelegt haben, um den Schein zu bekommen. Erst mal das auszurechnen, wie viel eine Meile ist. Eine Seemeile sind 1852 Meter. Aber warum spricht man denn Meilen? Das sind nicht die Meilen, die man kennt aus dem amerikanischen System. Die sind ja 1,6, glaube ich. Ne, genau, das ist nicht. Eine Seemeile ist nämlich angepasst an Längen und Breiten gerade. Man hat quasi einmal durch 60 sind der Minuten, durch 60 sind Meilen. Das heißt, du kannst dann mit einer Zirkelspitze kannst du genau eine Minute, also Grad ist jetzt angenommen, du rechnest einen Ort aus, wo du bist auf der Seekarte, da musst du ja geografisch angeben. Da bist du zum Beispiel 24 Grad, 53 Minuten Nord. Und diese Minute, das ist ein sechzigste eines Grades, das ist genau eine Seemeile. Heißt, es ist viel einfacher umzurechnen dadurch, wo den geografischen Punkt. Deswegen macht es total Sinn, dass man da auf Seemeilen gegangen ist. Okay. Aber, genau, und Knoten sind eine Seemeile pro Stunde. Sind die Seemeilen pro Stunde, Entschuldigung. Okay. Also heißt, du kannst das gut umrechnen. Aber deswegen die Frage an euch, plant den SKS zu machen, habt ihr da Empfehlungen oder seid ihr sogar Skipper? Weil da muss ich zwei Wochen lang auf einer See rumfahren und muss Teil des Schiffs, Teil der Crew sein. Ja, sehr gut. Macht das gerne zusammen, da findet ihr euch zusammen. Gross die MSU vor. MSU vor. Könnt ihr direkt in See stechen. Ja, ich hätte Bock darauf. Aber du musst dein Boot eigentlich selber bauen, oder? Ist das nicht auch der Traum? Also ich war lange unterwegs auf einer Messe, Karawan und Boot, war ich jedes Jahr in München und habe immer davon geträumt, mein eigenes Boot zu bauen.
Einen eigenen Karawan zu bauen.
Aber war die Karawan-Halle sehr leer, weil alle zu den Booten, zu dem cooleren Boot waren? Das war immer so, mein Vater wollte sein ganzes Leben lang einen Wohnwagen kaufen, aber wir hatten da nie wirklich Platz dafür und das funktionierte nicht, aber trotzdem hat er sich jedes Jahr die Wohnwagen angeschaut auf der Karawan und Boot und hat die sich angeguckt und ich war immer dabei und wir waren immer da und haben uns alle Wohnwagen angeguckt mit dem relativ, ja, mit der gewissen Überzeugung, wir werden das nie besitzen, aber wir träumen an diesem Tag, wir dürfen einmal träumen. Sie sind auch zum Träumen da. Absolut, da sind sie da, man geht da rein und überlegt sich, aha, wie ist das Wohnwagen, wo schläfst du, wo schlafe ich? Und dann holst sie dann Eis und gehst zu den Katamaranen und guckst sie die an mit dem Wissen, ich werde nie einen Katamaran besitzen, werde ich einfach nie haben, aber ich gucke sie mir an. Und da habe ich mir schon gedacht, eines Tages baue ich mir selber ein Boot und habe aber nie verstanden, wie das ist mit Nägeln, weil du darfst ja kein Metall verwenden, weil das rostet weg. Du musst das alles kleben und so und da bin ich dann, habe ich aufgehört zu träumen. Irgendwie ist ja so eine Wunschvorstellung dann auch da und die wird dann kaputt gemacht von der Realität. Du denkst, da haue ich dann die Nägel rein. Natürlich, je mehr du etwas weißt. Und du sagst, nee, das wird alles geleimt und du so, oh nee, leim ist es bürger. Wie viel zu geleim.
Nee, das will ich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber ich traue auch Kleber nicht über den Weg.
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Weil ich bin mir sicher, nichts hält langfristig, was geklebt ist.
Dafür habe ich schon zu viel gesehen. Man versteht auch nicht genau, was Kleber ist, wobei man ja sagen muss, ich habe mal letztens, glaube ich, so einen kurzen Podcast gehört, wo jemand gesagt hat, eigentlich ist Kleber viel besser als alle anderen Methoden, weil du könntest ja zum Beispiel, wenn du alles gut kleben kannst, kannst du, wenn du dann zum Beispiel so ein Auto oder irgendwas in der Machine nicht mehr brauchst, die einfach mal in so ein Lösemittel reinschmeissen, alle Teile lösen sich wieder, du kannst sie neu verarbeiten. Ja, aber allein das Lösemittel das wieder auseinander bringen, lässt mich ja schon an der Klebefertigkeit zweifeln. Das ist halt das Ding. Und stell dir mal vor, da laufen so jugendliche Jugendbanden, so Prankster herum mit so grossen Bottichen Lösemittel, die einfach überall so ein Lösemittel drüber kippen und die ganze Stadt zerfällt hinter denen so langsam. Das ist dann der Bösewicht für B-Man. Der Bösewicht ist Lösemittelmeister. Lösemittelmann. Der einfach überall, der so einen riesigen Kärcher hat mit Lösemittel drin und durch die Stadt und alle Gebäude kann er damit auflösen und die fallen in sich zusammen und niemand kann ihn aufhalten. Okay, das ist das Cinematic Universe, wo es den Bienenmann gibt, der Gelee Royale gegessen hat und aber die ganze Stadt auch aus Gleimt ist, weil das da die bessere Idee war. Ah, okay. Genau. Es gibt Leimer, der Jelly Royale gegessen hat und aber die ganze Stadt auch aus Kleeva geläumt ist,
weil das da die bessere Idee war.
Genau. Es gibt Leimer,
der wurde Bürgermeister
und der hat gesagt, wir
leimen jetzt alles hier.
Mr. Leimer. Alles wird geleimt
und weil das ist viel besser, das ist
viel billiger, man braucht nicht die ganzen
Nieten und so und man kann das dann alles
wieder auflösen. Weg mit den Nieten. Weg mit den Nieten.
Und wenn man sagt, oh, da haben wir ein Haus gebaut,
das sollte eigentlich da rüben stehen, ja, einfach
auflösen, hinstellen
und wieder aufbauen.
Ich habe mich auch gefragt, was ist Kleber?
Und so wie ich es verstanden habe, ist Kleber
einfach wie lange Schnüre.
Kleber ist einfach wie lange Schnüre,
die halt irgendwie auf dem mikroskopischen
Niveau ganz klein sind und die dann die beiden Dinge aneinander fesseln.
Das klappt nicht.
Ich denke mir auch, es klappt nicht. Ich dachte mir so, hör auf, es mir zu erklären, je mehr du es erklärst, desto mehr fällt die Welt sprichwörtlich auseinander, weil Kleber nicht mehr funktioniert.
Aber es klappt auch nicht.
Es klappt auch nicht.
In der Schulzeit wurde viel geklebt, im Kindergarten wurde viel geklebt. Wie viel hält davon heute noch? Ich hatte diese Pritzstifte, diese Uhu-Dinger, davon hat nichts gehalten, niemals, ausser man utopische Mengen an Klebstoff verwendet. Und dann war das eklig, da suppte es auch so durchs Blatt durch und sowas. Das funktioniert alles nicht. Und dann habe ich schon in meinem Leben zu viele Dinge plötzlich in der Hand gehabt, die mal geklebt waren oder sowas, als dass ich noch an den Kleber glauben kann. Also ihr könnt mir viel erzählen, aber ich bin Klebstoff-Skeptiker.
Ja, vor allem die absolute Monströsität der Klebewelt, der absolut lächerlichste, das Menitekel ist ja Kleister, weil Kleister funktioniert ja so, dass du zum Beispiel, wenn du diese Wahlplakate, du hängst ja das Wahlplakat an die Wand und schmierst den Kleister oben drüber. Oben drüber und dann klebt es dran. Normalerweise machst du den Kleber ja zwischen Klebfläche eins und Klebfläche zwei, aber bei Kleister... Aber für Tapeten nimmst du doch auch Kleister, das machst du hinten an die Tapete dran. Aber es geht auch, wenn du es oben drüber... Ich sehe das immer, wenn die die aufhängen, die Wahlparkate, die kleistern oben drüber und nicht drunter. Und da denke ich mir, jetzt hört doch mal, also Kleber ist ohnehin schon so konterintuitiv, das ist ja jetzt wirklich Wahnsinn. Also das ist ja wirklich... Ich würde behaupten, die haben es hinten geklebt und das, was du beobachtest, ist dann eher das Glattstreichen von vorne, was fürs Leinen, für dein ungeschultes Leinauge, Leimauge so aussieht. Also ich kann gut sein. Also ich wäre natürlich froh, wenn meine Welt dort gerettet werden würde. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass manchmal auch einfach drübergekleistert wird und das ergibt in meinen Augen überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Aber was ich cool finde, ich komme ja aus der Hobby-Ecke, sage ich mal. Ich habe ja lange Warhammer gespielt, das ist das Tabletop-Spiel, wo man so kleine Plastikfiguren hat. Ja, ich habe auch immer viel Revelle gebaut, Klebstoff-Graunwoll. Aber da gab es ja zwei verschiedene Arten von Figuren, einmal die aus Metall und einmal die aus Plastik, aus Resin. Und da gab es den Riesenunterschied, dass die Plastikfiguren hatten einen besonderen Kleber und der war der beste der Welt. Es hat so viel Spaß gemacht, mit dem zu kleben, weil was der gemacht hat, der hat die eine Plastikhälfte ein bisschen angeätzt. Der hat es so ein bisschen aufgelöst und die andere Seite auch. Also wie als würde man das anschmelzen und dann drückst du die zusammen und dann härten die wieder zusammen und sind mehr oder weniger eins. Das ist dann eins. Und da denke ich mir, das ergibt total Sinn. Aber der Rewelle-Klebe macht das auch, aber dann du hast nie die perfekte Menge hinbekommen. Ja, das ist schwer. Auch dünn, ja, ja. Du musst so dünn machen, dass wenn du es gegeneinander dötzt, was ja nicht funktioniert, eigentlich nichts an den Seiten rauskommen darf. Ja, ja, das ist schwierig. Aber das hat für mich total Sinn ergeben. Resin? Es hat richtig Spaß gemacht und da hatte ich wirklich Spaß dran und natürlich halt immer dran auch geschnüffelt so, wirklich immer, gehört einfach dazu. Ich glaube, das ist auch der Hauptgrund, warum Leute Modellbau betreiben, weil du halt immer in so einer angenehmen Wolke von ... In deinem Keller sitzend Klebstoff konsumieren kannst. Genau, schön, ich beliefern die Frau darf auf gar keinen Fall die Tür aufmachen.
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Weil du einfach so ein angenehmes Grundniveau an diesen ganzen Stoffen hast.
Lack, ja auch Lack sowas.
Aber was ist denn mit Resin?
Ja, grossartig.
Gibt es Resin-Minen?
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was das ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall grossartig. Ist Resin wertvoll? Ich glaube nicht. Es war sehr teuer, glaube ich, es lag aber nicht am Material, sondern an den Figuren. Und ja, viel Spaß meines Lebens gehabt, Sachen anzuschmelzen, zusammenzudrücken und sie zusammen aushärten zu lassen. Und er hat mir auch viel gelernt, weil auch... Das würde ich zum Beispiel sagen, das würde ich eher fast so in Richtung Löten schieben. Genau, das ist eigentlich kein Kleben mehr. Dann gab es natürlich die anderen Figuren, die aus Metall und die waren das absolute furchtbar. Die haben nie genau zusammengepasst, waren nie passgenau. Du hattest winzige Flächen, Metall ist schwer, da muss dann so der Arm von dem Ogre am Körper hängen, der Arm hat eine riesige Axt in der Hand, ist alles super schwer. Und es wird verbunden durch irgendwie einen Quadratmillimeter, wo du mit deinem dusseligen Sekundenkleber dir erstmal die Finger zusammenklebst. Dann irgendwie versuchst du dir das rauszuwischen, dann klebt dein Pulli irgendwie an der Wand und an deinem Pinsel. Alles klebt zusammen, du nimmst immer mehr Dinge aus deiner Umgebung in dich auf, du wirst immer grösser und unhandlicher. Aber es klebt auch nicht so doll an der Wand, dass du jetzt denkst, oh wie cool, ich hänge an der Wand, sondern dafür ist ja auch eher zu schlecht. Also ganz im Ernst, Kleber ist nicht the way to go. Wenn Kleber die Zukunft ist, dann will ich die Zukunft nicht erleben. Und damit entlassen wir euch in dieser Woche. Passt ein bisschen auf. Bleibt nicht hängen. Bleibt nicht hängen, im metaphorischen Sinne. Wir wünschen euch allesute und Florian und ich, wir heben ab. Wir haben es noch nicht vorgestellt, bis uns Florian will eben nicht.
Richtig, du bist Chef an Tietze. Ja genau, und ich will noch mal vielen Dank als Intro. Ja, vielen Dank an Max für das Intro, haut rein, macht's gut, schönen Abend. It's always purple. inszeniert jede ecke anders jede story echt späti-romantik an der trinkhalle beats unterm
förderturm sonnenuntergang auf der heide klingt anders ist es auch dein ruhrgebiet wo das
unperfekte perfekt passt inspiration für deinen next level städtetrip gibt's auf insta mein.ruhrgebiet